were you familiar with the game I didn't
know about the game before I got the job
and then I got the job and I found out
very quickly about the game it's a very
famous video game yeah I've heard that
um
you haven't played The Last of Us no
I needed it needed to be explained to me
um but when I when I when I got the job
I I uh I was very familiar with HBO I
was very familiar with Craig Mason who
created uh Chernobyl yeah and uh but I
called my sister who's got two teenage
boys uh uh and I was on speakers when
she answered she was dropping them off
at school and she's like what's going on
and I said well there's this job offer
and uh uh or opportunity
um that uh it's based actually on a
video game and uh Bruno and pedador my
nephew's names and they're like what is
it I was like it's called the LA The
Last of Us
you better get that job
you talk about getting that job at your
experience of getting that job quite
hazy I think yeah
I was in London I was in London
okay okay so it all happened very very
quickly it was a very strange thing
where it was read the scripts talk to
Craig uh uh us and then you know it was
getting later and later at night and uh
was shooting in London at the time and
uh
they needed me to stay up late to meet
the creator of the video game and the
executive producer Carolyn Strauss who
was on Game of Thrones and um to
continue kind of like you know
convincing trying to convince them to
hire me for the job and um by the time
it was all said and done it was late and
uh I uh
I took a an Ambien a sleeping sleeping
tablet that's that's strong to go to bed
yeah because I knew that I needed to
because I was at that point I was kind
of hyped up yeah you know what the next
day but yeah and I was excited about the
the prospect
so they called me and to tell me that I
had gotten the job but I'd already taken
the tablet
because I really didn't think I thought
that I would at least have to wait until
the next day you know and um okay yeah I
remember actually that's cool yeah yeah
I was like oh my God and then like a
couple of minutes on the call went by
apparently and I was like so what's up
did you did I get the job
what what are you talking about we
called you we told you you got the job
and I was like oh I did
what's it and I was like oh I took a
tablet
I thought that completely woke up in the
morning it was all like oh my god did I
get the job
hey they're in L.A I'm in London so I'm
gonna be waiting by the phone and
everything and and and I I had gotten
the job I'm surprised you kept the job
[Music]